how's the cobras today we're playing
some of the best simulator games on the
market
first off coffee simulator 2014 it's
outdated old coffee my favourite great
yes I'm fingering the mouse jokes sorry
alright let me grab it got it I got my
coffee everyone coffee don't fight me
don't you dare fight me coffee I worked
da na I worked too damn hard for this
coffee I spent 40 seconds why why is it
leaking damn you coffee
what is his moving finger Oh take it all
right I got it I got my coffee I'm ready
I got my [ __ ] ready to drink it how the
can use not move there be [ __ ] ah
damn it I spill the drop anything with
absorbs through the arrows I'm [ __ ] and
this is some call any games I gotta tell
you you bros always ask me how do I find
all these awesome games will buy the
darkest corners of the internet how to
eat it I hate y'all right we can do it
properly or nine or [ __ ] nine you
know what brah alright alright alright
where's the [ __ ]
my foot Headly back that are this is
gonna be really ready for this [ __ ]
take it take all of it
oh don't chase me with your mouth [ __ ]
oh well [ __ ] get enough what do you
want from me how many percent ten point
seven that is great simulator alright
next game is too MLG for you
sanic I don't remember signing like this
let's play okay alright how does it work
oh the ball is coming Oh
[Music]
beautiful
just beautiful oh my god a piece of art
[Music]
man people say I play bad games they
don't know what's next
here's a game that I'm very very excited
about I think this could be what they
say Cod killer
it's Salman simulator get get the joke
Cod killer [ __ ] you then all right so we
start off by not seeing anything but
then you are happy to see that you're a
Salman and then you start questioning
your life I can swim up that's good
there you go
it wouldn't be a Salman simulator if you
can't swim up I mean let's be honest
here objective collect food and swim up
the waterfall looks like I am not
capable of simple Salman principles by
eating worms and [ __ ] no all right can't
do it
cannot eat the [ __ ] worms all right
well let's swim up the waterfall then
cuz I don't know what else to do really
yes we're back in our natural habitat
but no Salman will break break free it
was a disappoints almond decided not to
go out the waterfall it was at this
point a Salman decided he wanted to be a
lawyer
Salman wanted to be free and no one
would stop his dreams sir Salman wrote
after the sunsets they came - what the
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] any
pooper what alright there's a robot
there they just steal [ __ ] from Stanley
parable well I'll go right then Jesus
seemed later but now you're just [ __ ]
with me now you're really [ __ ] with
me
single prayer I am so so very confused
I'm I am a little curious about the
multiplayer all the sudden this amazing
MMO game is unlocked where everyone is a
Salman and no one is unhappy when
Stanley came to a set of two open doors
multiplayer gaben we get gaben while I
was worth it
thank you thank you Lord gaben [ __ ] it
let's go to the waterfall I don't even
know oh we're swimming up the waterfall
amazing or not I don't know are we
what's on top of the waterfall only time
will tell
a tunnel all right let's go towards the
tunnel navigate through the cave life of
a Salomon man people don't understand
how hard it really is to just swim up
waterfalls and [ __ ] all day long look at
my butt while it jiggles isn't it nice
and hypnotizing doesn't it make you feel
small in such a large universe you were
here staring at a Solomon's ass doesn't
it make you happy just to make you sad
just to make you cry
there better be something amazing at the
end of this [ __ ] game that's all I'm
saying there we go so I can play us a
giraffe mode or non giraffe mode I think
I'll go on whatever the [ __ ] mode this
is okay what is this do we need this did
we really need this staircase simulate
open beta what does that even mean oh my
god well it's probably the best arcade
simulator I've ever played let me just
look at it so realistic next up we have
a very fitting game for me
alcoholic simulator 2015 this is my hand
whatever this is all right let me slap
you let me slap them oh it's Lea clear
my favorite beer let me slap you a slap
your beer is disrespecting me what do
you think I am some kind of non classy
alcoholic who doesn't drink from a glass
how do I grab it well I don't know why I
need to drink more I'm obviously drunk
as [ __ ] yes
now how does one drink it how just one
drink it
oh we have a glass well that's marvelous
dammit how do i dammit dammit know how
to [ __ ] the way glass stop but [ __ ]
glass piece of [ __ ] come here
now it's gonna go straight for it
woah
[Music]
we go here we go
I'm an alcoholic do des prés I'm an
alcoholic I think I don't know it works
oh just just just grab it man
who would have thought being an
alcoholic is this hard yeah that makes
sense
Graham rich oh yes yes how do I drink it
how do I drink it
how the [ __ ] do I drink people don't
understand how hard it is to bring it
out coholic hi did you bring me here to
apologize about that man said messy
stuff you said earlier aren't your eyes
too big oh yeah what the [ __ ] is that
please tell me that's a meatball nope
you are a net looking good man you need
some real training with the ladies I
said ladies I mean [ __ ] [ __ ] what
let's start this [ __ ] up bro the [ __ ]
are coming down and you got to spank
their ace is for real today my best
friend said I'm a bit overweight is this
true you're got it it could be a trap
you're fat ugly that's it make me yours
now you're ugly
how you dare I lost my pink head back
last night I loved it what do I do
follow me damn it are you not going to
take my body exactly [ __ ] I don't know
if you brought a bag which were in movie
I'm condom no pink little one yes I
think we did pretty well
yay move on bro the [ __ ] booty is waiting
[Music]
next simulator was made for the peopIe
in his repeat my jam it's called elder
simulator oh yeah yeah like the music
girl so I have to walk apparently my
legs are chopsticks when you get old a
little up I went to the toilet driving
to the store can't cook without
ingredients right I guess yeah Oh what
am i driving like a bottle over your
giant ball of beer my favourite type of
car
oh we made it let's get cooking up chop
it chop nailed it
Oh God how long is my hand what that all
right you become rubber when you get old
I will not question it oh it's damn it
it's that way I gotta take a [ __ ]
driving again why what am I going
hey let's go this way you made it
through but I just I would reverse all
right
but best whatever drifting simulator oh
yeah stunt park where you crash alright
so that was simulator games by me again
if you enjoyed hit that like button it
helps you out not me
it's really about you hear you you'll
feel better
something great might happen if you do
it and you won't find out if you don't
try it this guy recover resume that will
definitely help you and I shall always
stay awesome
whoa damn that [ __ ] Rick Minnick
allergies as [ __ ] kites Emma's a
dream first her sleeves with her